good morning everybody how's the latency
in the back can you hear me well no
fiber to the back yet sigh I understand
good morning good to see you a welcome
to to Luxembourg actually haven't been
here for quite a while I used to be
indeed a founder of RTL television in
the nineteen eighty nine so I've been
visiting this country a lot let's see if
this works yeah
I'd like to tell you something about the
state of tech as we see it at the start
at boot camp start a boot camp is an
accelerated for startups we see
approximately 15,000 startups every year
and we choose 150 of them so one percent
and we help them to grow in six months
as they would otherwise do within two
years so we see lots and lots of
innovation passing by and we also have a
second company it's called inner lips
and we basically help huge corporates to
to grow like startups so we use the same
methods that we do at start the boot
camp and we implement them for large
corporations so as a result we built
global innovation systems for startups
and for corporates and we are actually
pretty able to forecast the tech
developments the tech worlds in the next
12 to 60 months and I'm very happy today
that i can tell you something about what
we've we are for seeing for the
foreseeable future and with will which
will greatly help i think the fire fiber
industry let me first start that that
it's our opinion that we are still at
the very beginning of a new revolution
we call it the entrepreneurial
revolution and this revolution is
happening very very fast almost as fast
as fiber can can allow three times as
fast at least as the industrial
revolution we call it the the
entrepreneurial revolution because it
will result in end up since and instead
of startups if large corporations and
governments are not accelerating
themselves like startups are currently
doing the tech industry is basically
accelerating our whole society these are
Oliver and Wilbur Wright you may have
heard of them I assume any of you came
yesterday and maybe even today and
arrived at Luxembourg Airport and you
wouldn't have arrived there if these two
men wouldn't have invented the plane and
obviously they started in a garage
because Mark Zuckerberg started in a
garage Steve Jobs stars in the garage
they were not the first ones to start in
the garage
the Wright brothers started in that
garage and they build explain and of
course they weren't taken seriously by
the big steam lioness that were sailing
the ocean in those days in the late 19th
century because why would F would they
take the right brother seriously they
couldn't transport any passengers in
that first plane they couldn't transport
Eddie cargo and the plane could only fly
for 60 or 70 meters so why would you
take them seriously but we all know what
happens a few years later big passenger
planes were flying over those old steam
liners and basically were completely
changing and disrupting the
old-fashioned steam liner industry but
you know innovation never stops it's a
continuing process because KLM and other
major airlines that basically were
responsible for the disruption of those
steam liners actually were disrupted
themselves by companies like easyJet
which created whole new business models
for the airline industry innovation
never stops this is neil armstrong i had
a big pleasure of meeting him for a full
day a number of years ago and of course
Neil Armstrong was the first man to walk
on the moon and I was attending the
Wimbledon finals and was sitting next to
him and I said mr. Armstrong are you
willing to talk about it and he said
well we're here to watch the tennis but
why don't you think of one question that
you asked me about my first steps on the
moon and I said mr. Armstrong if you are
sitting in your garden late night and
you're watching a starry night and you
look up at the moon what do you think
how do you feel they said well first
that I was very privileged to be the
first man to walk on the moon but also
that can have the next slide please also
that planet earth looks much better from
the moon then the moon looks from Planet
Earth now i am a telling this story at
this fibre-to-the-home congress because
innovation works much better
if you have a clear target and if john f
kennedy in May nineteen sixty two would
have set we are going to bring a man to
the moon and we're going to bring him
safely back it probably would have taken
more decades than the original eight
years that it actually lasted before
Neil Armstrong walk the moon innovation
needs targets and one of your targets is
to spread fiber to the homes throughout
the world and if you really want to set
a date for that I'm convinced that it
will be actually much easier to do that
and of course we all know what the
result of those famous words in 1962 but
John F Kennedy were
at one small step for man one giant leap
for man I'm a big space enthusiasts and
these words always gave me a thrill how
many times I've seen them I can still
remember where I was when those first
steps on the moon were taken so we're
here to talk about fiber and of course
there's a tremendous need for speed by
the way the computer that Neil Armstrong
used to land on the moon was much weaker
than the smartphone that we currently
have in our pockets today but speed is
of course crucial and as a result fiber
is crucial for the further development
of the internet and we feel that
basically the internet is still in its
infant stage this is only the beginning
it's like an iceberg where only the tip
of the iceberg is currently above the
water and you know fiber of course it's
not something that was developed
yesterday it's been there for quite a
while your industry has been there for
quite a while and still you are the
future it's about time that together
we're going to accelerate that future
and I strongly believe that all optical
multi terabits networks are the future
and what we need to further grow our
economy let me tell you about where that
economy and where the tech world is
heading in the next few years in the
next five years it will grow from 500
billion to 2.2 trillion so there's a lot
of development and growth about to
happen and fiber once again will be
crucial to that and something about the
population are currently 70 7.2 billion
people but it will be more and more of
us so that creates new opportunities as
well but be aware that there is a new
generation coming up actually
Millennials are steering developments in
a very very great sense by 2020 about
half of the global workforce will
comprise of Millennials they are
literally ruling the world very very
soon and they have different well do a
different mentality they are used two
different things they are much more into
access than into ownership of things
they prove it with
services like Spotify for instance they
are very tech savvy and there's a big
emphasis on general wellness health is
important to them food is important to
them and they are used to flexible
workplaces and very soon much more
people will be online at this moment
just over three billion people are
online but it will be six billion people
in 2025 and they all need access to data
and the data will come through your
fiber and of course mobile as the
previous speakers mentioned as well it's
a crucial element there as well and I'm
happy to say if there's one word which
basically defines the state of the tech
industry today it is mobile and it
continues to grow rapidly smartphones
will become much more available there
will be even better network coverage and
mobile is now literally extending beyond
develop networks and latin countries at
this moment if you look at smartphones
there are approximately 3.6 billion
unique owners and by 2020 that will be
4.6 billion unique owners of smartphones
but that's still only sixty percent of
the global population by 2020 seventy
percent of the a of the world will be
covered by broadband and eighty percent
of the global population will be within
3 g.r each no 5g nor 43 g reach preview
old-fashioned huh and of course over the
tough surfaces like skype whatsapp
Facebook Messenger WeChat are becoming
increasingly popular and we think that
there will be even more popular because
of the growth of 4G networks and as a
result we feel that the traditional
telcos the telecom players will need
partnerships with those over the top
surfaces to really drive their long-term
revenues their current business model is
about to change because there is an
all-ip future solution which is vital to
retain customer relevance so 4G networks
are becoming dominant rapidly in the
fore in the developed world who here can
imagine that we would still be carrying
3G phones while only a couple of years
ago 4g was really
introduced and a development was very
very fast and of course we're now all
waiting for 45 g there will be 5.9
billion smartphones in 2020 and the data
traffic on those phones will have grown
tenfold from 2014 and of course videos
the key driver YouTube now generates
about fifty percent of its global
traffic by mobile Netflix takes fifty
percent of all primetime excess capacity
in the US in primetime and the latest
forecast from from Cisco actually from
last week says that by 2019 eighty
percent of all traffic on the internet
will be video and of course 5g is
already been tested it's it can be a
thousand times faster than 4g and of
course it will be of crucial importance
for for autonomous driving for VR and AR
and high-res video so South Korea has
stated that by 2020 the whole country
will be covered by 5g k pn t you know
huawei and ericsson are now testing in
the remarkable place of la person in the
netherlands which is a very small
village by the way and still with all
these developments actual mobile
internet penetration globally especially
in the developed countries is still
pretty limited but it is actually
growing and it brings for instance the
fin tech startups and the FinTech
industry to UM back populations and
there are already 255 life services
across 89 countries resulting things
like these as I look into the reason I
relaxed
we're as missing
Oh
put in true
be gone
he
what did you quit Nene butter
is a mihara
we the messe you do more
I
I
one
you
I met the founders of invest about four
years ago at an IBM startup competition
which they easily won and impressed by
that moment was a very small company and
nowadays it's really unthinkable that
they wouldn't be there in African
they're really allowing millions and
millions of people to lend money to each
other by mobile phones let's talk about
the internet of everything because we
can see in the applications from
thousands of startups that's really
really hot we look at it as a digital
nervous system for interactions between
people and machines and it's actually
creating lots and new of new
applications and lots of new surfaces
and allowing those services to prosper
we think it's key to smart cities and we
think that the internet thinks basically
has only just reached reached the public
I mean they're really only just
beginning beginning to become aware that
actually thinks can communicate
communicate with each other so we feel
that the number of connected things is
growing tremendously up until at least
2020 and probably far beyond that as
well our friends from pwc who buys by
the way helped us to create all these
slides think there will be 8 billion
things connected to the Internet in 2020
our friends from Cisco a partner and
start a boot camp by the way they think
it'll be 50 billion devices connected to
the Internet and we're not talking about
your smartphone we're not talking about
your tablet or your computer we're
talking about actual things like lights
like traffic lights anything you can
imagine will be connected to the
internet and and 1 million of new IOT
devices will be purchased every hour
every day in 2021 all connected to the
Internet hopefully through lots and lots
of fiber
and of course machine-to-machine
connections as a result are becoming
used because all those things are going
to talk to each other there were 243
million in 2014 1 billion devices
talking to each other in 2020 and many
of them by the way will not be here in
Western Europe but in asia-pacific we
see a tremendous growth and that's the
part of the world and by 2020 almost
half of all those mobile
machine-to-machine connections will take
place in that part of the world where
most people are living by the way of
course as well and growth is especially
coming from vertical slack automotive
healthcare utilities of course and smart
cities which are very important let's
address some of the growth factors for
the rapid growth of the Internet of
Things first low power network rollouts
very important increase standardization
because they're still not kind of a
Windows platform but then for the
internet of things improve regulation of
course governments have to play their
role there as well and of course a
greater assurance of end-to-end security
because security in this respect is of
course crucial let's talk about
wearables for a moment the Apple watch
actually I'm wearing it myself as well
we see a huge growth as well thirty-five
percent annual growth over the next five
years only 33 million devices last year
148 million devices by 2019 and still
that's not as much as probably you would
expect and we think that's because
people don't understand all the benefits
of smartwatches and other wearables yet
and the screens are still small the
battery time is still limited I have to
charge this at least once every year 24
hours and probably even more important
is that there is no killer app for
wearables yet but of course lots and
lots of companies are working on it and
we still feel that even despite this
lack of a killer app that there will be
an increased use especially for fintech
and also especially for enterprise
purposes so within the wearables the
SmartWatch will be by far the most
important to the device forty percent of
all those smart watches in a few years
from now will be Apple watches and we
think that the smart which will grow by
forty-one percent per year over the next
five years but in order for it to really
become mainstream it has to become a
standalone device which you can actually
use without carrying an iphone in your
in your suit and wearables are also
really driving IOT and health starters
we can see that very very clearly then
not yet dominant however in 2016 and if
you look at companies controlling those
wearables and also as a result
controlling part of the Internet of
Things we think that Apple and Google
will continue to dominate at least for
the next five years which brings us to
digital health of course in important
elements of those wearables four of the
five last quarter's we've seen more than
200 million dollars investment in
digital health financing from many many
large corporations by the way as well
and apps are really becoming a regular
part of care a care now you go to your
doctor and the doctor will write you a
prescription some medicines but one day
and the day is very very close a doctor
will say well why don't you start using
this or that app and see for yourself
what is happening with your sleep
pattern for instance healthy food weight
loss exercise education and information
are all becoming much more important to
the health industry and you can off all
control them and guide them by using the
right apps thirty-three percent of all
US hospitals are already offering apps
but the lack of funding is still a main
barrier for effective use so the top
five digital health categories for the
next few years that we foresee are the
following cost transparency very
important big data and analytics
wearables are just mentioned but also
real time healthcare is very important
those wearables will
in your clothing actually and it may
very well be that one day your doctor
will be able to see by the mere fact
that you are wearing a certain suit or a
certain a piece of clothes hey you're
not healthy anymore there's something
happening please come and see me so
personal medicines and information are
becoming very important and of course it
with all those data coming from your
body going to a central server somewhere
going to your doctor cyber security is
very very important it's by far the
hottest and also the fastest growing
tech tech sector that we currently see
and you know already cyber attacks are
costing 400 to 500 billion dollars a
year the cyber insurance market as a
result has grown from 1 billion to two
and a half billion in two years that's a
huge growth but it's still very limited
if you compare it to the cost of of
cyber attacks and what it may do not
just to individual people but to
companies and two brands as well so we
see in huge growth in cyber security in
the cyber security industry in the next
five years it's creating lots and lots
of new opportunities and if you have a
cousin here or there who doesn't know
what to do with this life and it just
comes out of high school well advised
him or her to go into the cyber security
because he will not be unemployed for
the next few decades Eric Smith the
chairman of Google actually said that
fifty percent of all current jobs will
disappear but also like the prime
minister mentioned as well earlier this
morning new jobs will arise and already
in the u.s. there are 200,000 vacancies
in cyber security and by 2019 it will be
one and a half million and globally it
will be millions and millions of jobs
and you see that the security services
market as a result is of course growing
at a tremendous pace as well from eight
billion today to thirty billion by 2020
so if you don't like the fiber to the
home industry anymore there are lots and
lots of other opportunities as well but
if I were you I would stay in fiber
because fiber is crucial to thin tech
and you see a lot of growth in the
FinTech the financial
industry at this moment as well fintech
continues to grow enormously in the next
few years and the UK actually not
luxembourg although luxembourg is
important to the financial industry of
course as well but the UK is really set
to become the global center and we see
lots and lots of start of still working
with with the bitcoin but other
cryptocurrencies companies are here to
stay as well the blockchain of course is
way more important that then the Bitcoin
itself gives an example the world makes
500 billion electronic payments every
year to take thirty six trillion hours
to process and cost people tens of
billions in fees money uses old
inefficient technologies that are slow
inexpensive networks the Internet has
made the world a flatter more connected
place that payments have not kept up
it's time for money to evolve
introducing ripple a new global payment
network that does foot what the internet
did for information with ripples so as
easy as email you can send currency of
any kind to anyone in in seconds for
next to nothing it create businesses
helps existing businesses grow supports
powerful a plans gives people control of
their money and makes the global economy
access billions of people without access
to banks and financial institutions
future of money is going to be a smarter
faster more efficient at bro's place for
everyone come join the growing ribbon
committee and help build the network
that will transform the way the world
does business yes money flowing with
enormous speeds around the globe ripple
is just an example but traditional
financial institutions are now really
seriously interested in small startups
in those guys working in those small
garages of this world basically trying
to disrupt them and you see the big
banks really doing lots and lots of R&D
investments at the moment beautopia tech
is really disrupting those banks they
are not doing these these banks are not
interested because they are just nice
now they have to be
to be active in this field because they
are really feeling this in their core
core business so there's a big search in
peer-to-peer lending at the moment
startups are growing tremendously fast
there are landing large deals also with
traditional banks at the moment and of
course alternative payment methods are
growing at an incredible rate as well if
you're talking about the need of
reducing latency here's a prime example
and we see that crowdfunding is here to
stay it's still small but it won't go
away anymore and also wealth management
also an area where time is of crucial
importance is moving into a new era
there's a big shift in mindset there's
much more attention and power to the
small investor is always running behind
the professional players but you now see
that high net worth individuals are
being able to to act to get access to
tools and apps that basically put them
on a level playing field with those
professional players so as a result
wealth management startups are becoming
prominence and they give their clients
the same opportunities as the large
investors and automated investment
management will very soon be normal
normal there will not be anybody nor
human being interfering in the trading
of shares for instance of public
companies I already mentioned a little
earlier that we see lots and lots of
developments in the Asia Pacific also in
the financial industry Inc you can
clearly see that at this moment Western
banks are weakening if your company is
not active in AC in the Asia and Pacific
area at the moment I would strongly urge
you to to move in that direction we see
that those Western banks is that they
understand the digital is important but
they think it's somehow kind of a
solution set while the global economic
balance is shifting from north south to
south south so the Western banks are
really not just because of their their
current problems are in trouble because
they are not innovating fast enough and
are really being caught up by their
competitors in in asia-pacific
and the leadership is very much oriented
to work products but not really looking
at process innovation if you want to
innovate you have to allow people to
make mistakes I once founded a sports
channel and that sports TV channel was
only broadcasting for three months and
then it went south for numerous reasons
and I had invested 20 million euros of
20 million guilders about 10 million
euros myself in that sports channel and
it was I was working at animal at that
moment and it was really affecting our
stock price so my two co-founders of
animal and myself we decided to buy the
shares from the company to really make
certain that our stock price would not
be affected anymore and I so so yet so
we had to put up 10 million each and
when the station actually went down the
drain and wasn't broadcasting anymore i
met my two co-founders and one of them
was had been very negative for the whole
project from from actually day one and
when I met him he said you look like a
knockdown boxer and I said that's too we
lost a lot of million we have millions
we had to fight to fire over 400 people
he said the roots what you have to do
take a three-week vacation the first
week think about how all this could
happen the second week you really try to
relax in the third week you're going to
think about how we are going to earn
this money back because I want every
single cent back and so I took that
break and I came back and I came up with
three ideas and and one of those ideas
was basically needing an investment of
200 million and within five minutes
those two co-founders of me said roots
let's do it let's invest another two and
hundred million and do it again and I
said guys we just lost 200 million out
of which 10 million from each individual
of the three of us how can we do that
and they said you know you made a big
mistake and as a result you lost and we
lost a lot of money but we are very
certain you're not going to make that
mistake again so just go out and make
certain that this next project works and
that we all get our money back and
actually that's what we did and within
18 months we earned all the money back
but if you want to innovate you have to
trust people you have to be able to let
them make their mistakes now if people
can't feel you cannot try new things if
you don't try new things you can't
innovate you need to trust people and
basically it requires a whole new
mindset within major corporations and
especially big banks because they are of
course very focused on avoiding risk and
on compliance and things like like that
so leave us within the financial
industry actually need a vision they
have to develop a vision for the next 10
to 20 years and there's an urgent need
to host an intergenerational dialogue if
if you really feel hey what's happening
in the tech industry i can't really
really connect to it anymore i can't
follow with it anymore try and find a
young mentor who can guide you at GE
jack welch wants their legendary co
forced any office colleagues above the
age of 45 to find a mentor below the age
of 25 and it really works it's a key
ingredient of what we do at start at
boot camp as well so just a few words
about fintech in this year in 2016 we
see an increased use of alternative
payment solutions lots and lots of them
the embedding of payments in apps like
facebook twitter google pinterest
especially in social media so you can
instantly buy something that you that
you see and here's another example
you
this is a fascinating company cabbage
actually what they do if you if you ask
for a loan at the bank if you're an
entrepreneur usually in the Netherlands
it takes six to eight weeks before you
here usually know and every now and then
they say yes the cabbage platform
basically takes your input and within
seven minutes they tell you if you will
get alone yes or no and they are aiming
to bring that back to within one minute
so you apply for a loan within one
minute here yes or no and in that one
minute day of check your credentials in
180 points so that's really fascinating
and I'm sure that if we could add fiber
to the home throughout the world that
that one minute can be reduced probably
even further ING Bank by the way
invested recently in cabbage and they
are going to roll out cabbage in Europe
as well this is an American startup
which is of course crucial for the
sharing economy as well that's rapidly
growing and here's probably the best
example of the sharing economy uber
which raised eight billion since 2009
it's the worst world most valuable
private startup 62 billion of market cap
at this moment it's currently operating
in 360 cities in 63 countries
unfortunately not yet in Luxembourg I
noticed yesterday and it spent about 35
million per week and it's of course a
huge hit everybody thinks it's a big
success but last year let's not forget
that they lost about two billion dollars
but it's really really investing heavily
in a new ride sharing service disrupting
traditional taxes and capsule even
further called uber pool I was in the
New York last week I used to burp all
there and it works magnificently well
but thirty percent of uber strips which
we all know as the u.s. San
francisco-based company is already
taking place in China and you would
think that as a result Eber is by far
the largest cap surface in China
actually it's not DD qua di hope i
pronounced it properly instead by far
the most popular ride hailing cap a pin
in China the sharing economy provides
extra income
reciprocity social interaction to lots
and lots of people it's easy to join
everybody can use their car to provide
rights or use their apartment to provide
them to the Airbnb s of this world and
it's interesting to note as we already
mentioned the Millennials a little
earlier seventy percent of the sharing
workers in this hugely growing economy
are 18 to 34 years of age and forty
percent of those people driving uber
caps actually have a college degree so
the IOT which we just mentioned the
Internet of Things is changing from the
Internet of Things to the Internet of
shared things and Millennials I already
mentioned them to you earlier they are
paving your way and they are sharing way
more than others and they demand and and
reach as a result lower prices and
there's a higher the amount of work we
were talking about new jobs that are
being created here's a prime example
which brings me to the smart sitting and
living which is a crucial element of the
Internet of Things cities are of course
getting smarter and smarter driven by
our three driven by big data and driven
no doubt by fiber as well and it
provides for safer living environments
less pollution less traffic congestion
and real-time surface networks and of
course an important element in that city
of the future and the in the sharing
economy is autonomous driving here's an
example
today we have something extra special
for you guys and you guys would be some
of the first people outside of our team
and outside of Google to ever ride in it
okay here we go there's no steering
wheel in it was a big decision for us to
go and start building our purpose-built
vehicles for us and really their their
prototype vehicles they were a chance
for us to explore what does it really
mean to have a self-driving vehicle but
in the small amount of time we've been
working on it and we have functional
prototypes and it's exciting oh it's
really cool it was like really kind of a
space-age experience
really yeah Annie and Julie will be
probably driving those cars on the
day-to-day basis so very very soon
because we really see that that lots and
lots of large corporations are now
moving into autonomous driving but
obviously our millions of people are
going to drive autonomous cars that all
have to be connected to the internet
with no latency fiber once again it's an
essential element to create it and
ninety percent of car accidents are
caused by human error so if you probably
feel a bit a little bit uncomfortable
when you first step into such a car bear
that in mind so increase safety Road
capacity fuel efficiency and reduce
pollution I really think that autonomous
driving is really important for our
future it's by far the fastest growing
field in automotive it requires the most
complex coding that car makers actually
ever faced and of course correct
software integration is paramount for
safety but things look look right and
actually on the 18th of March 50
autonomous driven cars are going to go
on the highways of the Netherlands my
home country very very soon I don't own
the car but I'm very curious to see what
will happen happen there that day of
course there's some risks as well and
that's once again why fiber is so
important system failures you won't
don't want to die because the computer
computer crest cyberterrorism uses
taking additional risk when they feel
safer actually and even increased
traveling resulting from faster or
cheaper cars so the current congestion
may be solved by autonomous driving but
then once the roads are pretty empty
again we may also use them much more
again so that's that's a risk so by 2025
fifteen to twenty percent will be four
cars will be highly autonomous driving
test slice or a way hat in there and but
truly autonomous driving is likely to
still be below five percent but I was in
Mountain View in California a few months
ago and I saw the Google cars driving
and actually they look pretty normal a
bit small that that I must emphasize so
in 2013
we'll be implementation for taxis and
car sharing in 2040 we feel that some of
the highway lanes may be really
dedicated to autonomous cars only and by
2050 basically we'll have to change our
highways or roadways and their design
and management practices because then
it'll be very normal to see the majority
of cars being autonomously driven and
maybe by 2060 it will be forbidden to
drive your own car that's sad news for
the people at the BMW Emma Cedars well
you are aware keytek players are
involved Google Apple uber Tesla and
incumbents like fort and General Motors
are struggling to catch up but I'm
pretty convinced they will be able to do
them and they may be able to team up as
well with the players like Google etc
and you know the technology is all there
I mean those autonomous cars are driving
and the fiber is available although we
can expand on that but legislation is
still a bigger hurdle than technology so
there's a real challenge for the
governments of this world this is a nice
one as well
yeah this is nice isn't it the delivery
of a package by amazon prime air which
is actually really testing these things
and i heard they are already delivering
on a few of the islands in the north of
Germany drones are growing at a
tremendous pace the drone invasion is
literally under way and mainly because
consumers are more and more looking for
instant gratification they buy something
today they want don't want it tomorrow
they wanted today and preferably even in
the next half hour and that's amazon
prime target at this moment to deliver
anything you order within half an hour
we're months away of those surfaces
being really implemented by Amazon
drones in some circumstances are 10
times cheaper and faster than any
alternative and it may sound strange but
they are ideal for less developed
countries the biggest enemy of drones of
course is the weather you don't want to
have lots of drones flying above a city
when there's when it's really stormy
weather and of course once again just
like with the autonomous car regulating
framework especially in the US but also
in Europe still appears to have stalled
in the Netherlands by the way we are
brief advanced on that but Amazon and
Google are pushing hard so the question
is not will drones in the end actually
deliver to your home the question is
when will it really happen and it'll be
soon by 2020 there will be a 140 billion
drone market fifty-six percent of it in
the u.s. twelve percent in China and
there are some leftovers for Europe as
well and of course you may have heard of
Google's Project wing which delivers
items within five miles not within half
an hour now they deliver within five
minutes so there's a lot happening there
and of course the weapons is it really
taking the cost of moving information to
almost zero and and the drones will do
precisely that for physical items and
once again connections ladies and
gentlemen
are crucial importance which brings me
to ecommerce I'm speeding up a little
bit because got about five minutes left
and I see Nadia looking slightly worried
just some trends about the e-commerce
last mile delivery you already saw an
example of that very important hyper
local City sensors part of of course the
Internet of Things and smart cities and
open data are very important they're
just four months ago three months ago we
reach the very important moment in the
history of the internet 51-percent the
majority of all internet usage by that
moment was mobile and I don't think it
will ever change and it will continue to
grow tremendously Mobile is really at
the heart of future ecommerce and it
also creates whole new logistic
challenges there's a huge need for a new
supply chain same-day delivery means
that actually new air freight facilities
will be needed and fulfillment centers
are built next to airports if you own a
piece of ground next to Luxembourg
Airport you're a lucky person and it'll
change the landscape around them so we
will move from mega distribution
facilities too much smaller fulfillment
centers and package pickup options
covering the last mile will be all over
the country social media just a few
words of course all of you by now are
using Facebook and Twitter and Pinterest
but we see a development there as well
messaging services like whatsapp are
really becoming more powerful than
social media themselves everybody looked
up pretty strange when they heard that
Mark Zuckerberg for facebook bought
whatsapp for 19 million u.s. dollars a
few years ago but i think it was was
well worth the money because basically
facebook was protecting its own interest
by that way whatsapp Facebook Messenger
very gleeko clear global global leaders
and some other players are dominating
locally but messaging services are
really becoming platforms where you can
advertise where you can order are
becoming ecommerce platforms themselves
as well
among social media snapchat is of course
growing very very fast 200 million users
now mainly young people it's the key
driver for vertical video uses I mean
we're used to watch 16 by 9 TV but we
see everybody vertically shooting their
video for social media and it's
important to notice that only in 2010
less than six years ago five percent of
all viewing was vertical now it's
already twenty nine percent and its
continuing to grow so a full screen
vertical video ads on chat snapchat
having nine times higher completion rate
than horizontal but there's nails still
no a proof on business model for snapped
yet yet so we'll see what will happen
there and we'll see what happened with
Twitter in the next few months and just
a few words about media because I think
they are providing you see opportunities
for fiber as well non digital will still
contribute let's not forget that well
over eighty percent of all blubber
global consumer revenues in 2019 but new
products expand the number of
multitasking moment so people are not
just watching TV they're also watching
the newspaper on their tablet or they're
using their apps on the tablet or on the
mobile phones so consumers are really
calling the shots we were hurt people
talking about the huge need for
transparency we are moving to a fully
transparent society and content
experience really Trump's the delivery
platforms if you are able to deliver
your content in a proper way that's much
more important than the platform that
you're that you use so streaming audio
Spotify Apple music really growing very
very fast while radio is still dominant
YouTube currently fifty-three percent
and Spotify are leading but Apple and
Apple music are rapidly catching up and
by 2020 only four years from now digital
music surfaces will generate about 10
billion in revenues and fifty percent of
that will be streaming lots and lots of
me need for bandwidth and little latency
so cable and tv
TV also arrived for disruption TV has
reached its tipping point situations
really comparable to print in 2005 four
percent degrees in users year or year
Netflix and YouTube are grabbing
traditional viewers TV ad spending is
decreasing so if you want to do business
I'd go to Netflix if I were you and not
to to directly traditional TV players
all day although they do their utmost to
catch up and we were talking about
Millennials video on the amount is of
course key to them as well really driven
by Millennials a truly on the mounted
generation thirty-three percent watch is
more video on the amount than
traditional TV and one in four uses
watches VOD daily and five percent of
all users doesn't even have a standard
TV service at all anymore so finally
ladies and gentlemen the entrepreneurial
revolution has only just began to be
gone the internet is still in its infant
H if you feel we're way behind how can
we enter all this you know it's still
early days you there are lots and lots
of opportunities still available just
give it a try and with all these things
which have shown to you in the last 45
minutes fiber is crucial fiber is
crucial to the future of the internet it
is our future so I'd like to thank you
very much for your attention I would
like to leave you with my main
ingredients in life I wake up every
morning and I think you know I have to
dance again today like nobody is
watching me I have to laugh again like
I've never been heard before and I have
to innovate today like my life depends
on it thank you very much for your
attention see you soon